so we have an f of X right over here it
is defined piecewise for X less than
zero f of X is X plus one for X is
greater than or equal to zero f of X is
cosine of PI X and we want to evaluate
the definite integral from negative one
to one of f of X DX
and you might immediately say well which
of these which of these versions of f of
X am I going to take the antiderivative
from because from negative one to zero I
would think about X plus one but then
from zero to one I would think about
cosine PI X and if you were thinking
that you're thinking in the right
direction and the way that we can make
this a little bit more straightforward
is to actually split up this definite
integral this is going to be equal to
the definite integral from negative one
to zero of f of X DX plus plus the
integral from zero to one of f of X DX
now why was it useful for me to split it
up this way in particular to split it up
split the interval from negative one to
one split it into two intervals from
negative one to zero and zero to one
well I did that because zero x equals
zero is where we switch where f of X
switches from being X plus 1/2 cosine PI
X so if you look at the interval from
negative 1 to 0 f of X is x plus 1 so f
of X here is X plus 1 and then when you
go from 0 to 1 f of X is cosine PI X so
cosine of cosine of PI X and so now we
just have to evaluate each of these
separately and add them together so
let's take the definite integral from
negative 1 to 0 of X plus 1 DX well
let's see the antiderivative X plus 1 is
antiderivative X is x squared over 2 I'm
just incrementing the exponent and then
dividing by that value and then plus X
and you could view this I'm doing the
same thing if this is X to the 0 it'll
be X to the first X to the first over 1
which is just X and I'm going to
evaluate that at 0 and subtract from
that it evaluated at 1 sorry it evaluate
at negative 1 and so this is going to be
equal to if I evaluate it at
zero let me do this in another color if
I evaluate it at zero it's going to be
zero squared over two which is well I'll
just write it zero squared over two plus
zero well all of that's just going to be
equal to 0 minus it evaluated at it
evaluated at negative one so minus
negative one squared negative one
squared over two plus negative one so
negative one squared is just one so it's
1/2 plus negative one 1/2 plus negative
one is or 1/2 minus one is negative one
half so all of that is negative one half
but then we're subtracting negative one
half zero minus negative one half is
going to be equal to positive one half
so this is going to be equal to positive
one half so this first part right over
here is positive one half and now let's
evaluate the integral from zero to one
of cosine pi I don't need that first
parenthesis of cosine of PI X DX what is
this equal to now if we were just trying
to find the antiderivative of cosine of
X it's pretty straightforward we know
that the derivative with respect to X of
sine of X is equal to cosine of X cosine
of X but that's not what we have here we
have cosine of PI of PI X so there is a
technique here you could call it u
substitution you could say u is equal to
PI X if you don't know how to do that
you could still try to think about think
this through where we could say all
right well maybe it involves sine of pi
X somehow so the derivative with respect
to X of sine of PI X would be what well
we would use the chain rule it would be
the derivative of the outside function
with respect to the inside or sine of PI
X with respect to PI X which would be
cosine of PI X and then times the
derivative of the inside function with
respect to X so it would be x pi or you
could say the derivative of sine PI X is
I cosign of PI X now we almost have that
here except we just need a PI so what if
we were to throw a PI right over here
but so we don't change the value we also
multiply by 1 over pi so if you divide
and multiply by the same number
you're just you're not changing its
value 1 over pi times pi is just equal
to 1 but this is useful this is useful
because we now know that PI cosine PI X
is the derivative of sine PI X so this
is all going to be equal to this is
equal to 1 let me let me take that 1
over PI so this is equal to 1 over PI x
now we're going to evaluate so the
antiderivative here we just said a sine
sine of PI X and we're going to evaluate
that at 1 and at 0 so this is going to
be equal to 1 over PI 1 over PI not pi
my hand is not listening to my mouth 1
over pi times sine of PI sine of PI
minus sine of minus sine of PI times 0
which is just 0 well sine of PI that's 0
sine of 0 is 0 so you're gonna have 1
over pi times 0 minus 0 so this whole
thing is just all going to be equal to 0
so this first part was 1/2 this second
part right over here is equal to 0 so
the whole definite integral is going to
be 1/2 plus 0 which is equal to 1/2 so
all of that together is equal to 1/2